When knitting in stitch pattern,
it's important to consider the end needles.
On this manual machine, I've selected some
needles and I set the carriage to slip.
You can see the large floats that are
formed.
But notice that because the end needle was
left in B or working position,
when I knit across, the end
needle didn't knit.
And when I knit back, the working yarn will pass
back, distorting that slipped
stitch and forming a hole.
To complete the slip stitch,
I need to make sure that the
machine knits the end needle.
I'm manually knitting this end stitch.
And this is what I want the row to look
like; the float going all the way
to the edge of the knitting.
Since this is a manual machine,
I'll pull out that end needle to middle
position along with the rest
of the pattern needles.
Now, when I knit across the needle,
will knit-along with all the other needles
that are in middle position
and the needles and B will slip.
By selecting that end needle,
the slip float travels across the row
and all the stitches form properly.
On some automatic patterning machines,
you can control the end needle selection
and you can program your pattern
for end needle selection as well.
But no matter what machine you have,
be aware of what's happening
along the edge of your knitting.